tu as vécu des moments difficiles à ces
derniers temps parce qu'on est tous très
peur pour toi
vraiment tu as pensé à tous les enfants
un moment tu t y fait peut-être pour
voir mes enfants
non j'ai pas pensé à ça sert il et pour
être honnête avec toi ça s'est passé
extrêmement vite
en l'espace de 24 heures je passe de 2
10% de poumons affecté à 80 pratiquement
et je tombais une saturation de 82 donc
j'ai énormément de mal à respirer je
rentre directement en réa et j'ai l'âge
et le médecin qui vient boire et qui me
dit écoutez monsieur zougari je vais
être honnête avec vous le médecin était
jeune il me dit je vous cache pas que
vous êtes mal en point vous avez une
chance sur quatre de vous en sortir et
je n'ai pas de produit miracle à vous
donner
la seule chose si vous voulez vivre il
va falloir vous mettre sur le ventre
voilà dormir sur le ventre parce que
lorsque vous dormez sur le ventre ça
ouvre plus les poumons et comme mes
poumons a été infecté le fait de rester
sur le dos bas ça les débats donc j'ai
demandé à parler à ma femme de suite à
ce moment là je ne bouge plus les gens
mais j'ai uniquement mon bras droit et
bouge il ya ma femme écoute que j'aime
et que qu'elle protège mes enfants mes
frères sont là alors je me répète parce
que je l' ai dit plusieurs fois mais
avec vos confrères mais c'est je vais
pas tricher avec vous et avec qui que ce
soit je vous raconte ce qui s'est passé
réellement
et à ce moment là je dis j'accepte ce
qui m'arrive parce que je commence à
avoir un voile blanc qui arrive et là je
me laisse aller je me laisse aller parce
que on peut pas lutter il n'y a pas de
ya pas de n'y a pas de surhommes dans la
maladie voilà donc à ce moment là je me
laisse aller j'accepte mon destin tu te
sens tu vas partir
ouais parce que la douleur est horrible
la douleur est horrible je je j'ai c'est
comme si tu t'es date est allongé qui
avait quatre personnes qui étaient sur
ta poitrine
donc le moindre effort ça te pompe une
énergie et avec le mal de crâne et tout
ça et puis si tu veux la réanimation
on ne ressort jamais inde m j'ai encore
des particules de kobe dans mes poumons
j'étais hier chez le pneumologue
ça va bien mais je suis pas encore sorti
quoi je pense que j'en ai en moi pour un
an
j'ai repris le sport parce que j'ai pas
envie d'attendre un an et que j'ai envie
de revenir le plus rapidement possible
je discute énormément sur les réseaux en
privé avec des gens aussi
d des proches qui sont malades qui ont à
peu près le même parcours que moi alors
là vous voyez un peu essoufflée mais il
ya des jours où je suis pas essoufflé
mais il ya des jours où ce qu'on vit de
cette merde m'emmerde qu'il prenait au
sérieux tu vas prenez au sérieux cette
épidémie a totalement totalement
je viens d'une famille où l'éducation et
le respect un nez en pole position et je
suis quelqu'un de très très safe a ouais
je me faisais tester toutes les trois
semaines en plus j'ai un métier
d'animateur qui me rappelait pas tomber
malade et j'ai une famille à nourrir
donc j'ai été testés lorsque j'ai chopé
le kobus j'avais mon masque ffp2 et je
faisais toujours attention mais j'ai
toujours respecté
ouais aujourd'hui mon vous me dire c'est
vrai que je suis on est tous très émus
de voir renaître son thème énormément et
aujourd'hui je trouve qu'au contraire
ton témoignage
il est très important parce qu'il ya
plein de gens aussi qui vont ressentir
ce soir qui dit ça y est c'est parti
c'est les terrasses tilling vous le dire
c'est une force de la nature
ouais ben ayliffe attention et s'il voit
là il dit ont ils encore des séquelles
ils en ont encore il est passé très près
de la mort et je pense à tous les jeunes
qui nous regardent ce soir et qui vont
se dire ce soir on va sortir ce soir on
va on va en valais on va on va faire les
gros varan va y pense on va se coucher à
penser à ça est ce que mon dire aussi
c'est pas un vieillard
voilà et c'est vrai que je trouve que ce
que tu fais en ce moment aussi de
raconter ton histoire très important
ouais c'est important pour moi parce que
j'ai reçu
je m'attendais pas à voir un élan de
solidarité de recevoir des messages
d'amour et de bienveillance et de par le
monde à j'en ai reçus de partout
donc c'était pour moi quand il nous
arrive des choses bien c'est à dire de
revenir à la vie de pouvoir les rendent
un peu comme dans la vie quand il
t'arrive des choses mais il faut les
rendre un peu comme ce que tu fais en
aidant les gens en faisant plein de
choses mais ce qui est important c'est
que on me dit que j'ai un fort caractère
ou que je lâche pas je peux t'assurer
que lorsque j'étais au service des
maladies infectieuses m'est arrivé de
perdre le moral et la lumière je ne
pense pas qu'il faut la faire sur moi
cyril il faut la faire sur ces femmes
qui m'ont qui m'ont l'avait kim
et kim ont essuyé ces internes qui sont
qui sont exceptionnels de par leur
courage parce qu'ils travaillent dans
des conditions j'ai vu dans les
conditions sur lesquelles ils
travaillaient en rayon ou dans le peu de
moyens qu'ils ont l'hôpital public et je
suis tombé sur vraiment sur des
guerrières qui m'en retourner pardonne
moi de parler comme ça mais kim ont
essuyé est lavé au moment où je voulais
pas comblés avec on voit tout nu parce
que j'avais honte
et si elle m'écoute et tous les corps
hospitalier
pardonnez moi je gère des fois j'ai des
manques de mémoire et aucun problème ces
boules vers l'hôpital public
je vous remercie du fond du coeur et je
n'oublierai jamais jamais
oui
est-ce que ce qu'a traversé quand tu
nous a raconté j'ai toujours où vous
vivez le truc que tu nous la raconter
quand tu te mettais sur levante quand tu
t'es vu partir est ce que ça va changer
des choses notre façon de voir l'année
non encore une fois je reviens à
l'éducation parce que c'est ce qui me
permet avec le socle familial d'avancé
et d'avoir rencontré aussi des gens
formidables qui sont là aussi ici et qui
je collabore et j'ai toujours aimé la
vie parce que on voyait nos parents
travailler dur donc l'exemple qui nous
ont donné nous ont appris à respecter la
vie et à l'aimer comme il se doit
je ne suis pas plus amoureux de la vie
après le coc vide je suis très heureux
en tout cas de vous revoir et de revoir
mes enfants ma femme et les gens que
j'aime
mais je continue j'étais pressé de
travailler et de reprendre le travail
parce que le travail
pour moi c'est important mon esprit a
besoin de deux avaient besoin de se
remettre au travail
vous savez je collabore et je travaille
avec avec le mari de mme géraldine que
voilà je m'éclate depuis cinq ans un sur
rmc et ma convalescence ne passera aussi
que par le travail
voilà donc c'est important pour moi oui
la famille bien sûr mais tu sais quand
tu acceptons destin et a décidé
d'accepter la mort parce que c'était
doux c'était quelque chose de doux je
n'ai pas je n'ai pas souffert au
suffoquer je me suis juste laisser aller
un peu comme comme une anesthésie et
c'était doux c'était beau voilà il nous
est dit je suis en train de mourir vous
pensez vraiment que vous étiez en train
de mourir ouais parce que à ce milliard
il ya un moment où je vois un voile
blanc je vois plus personne vous savez
quand vous rentrez en réa ça il ya douze
personnes autour de vous vous êtes piqué
aux artères mon cas des douleurs de
partout vous êtes branché vous avez des
débris partout donc c'est c'est une
ambiance particulière
l'art est assez soit vous en sortez soit
vous y rester voilà moi de ce que j'ai
vu je n'ai pas vu de personnes âgées
j'ai vu des jeunes de mon âge au service
des maladies infectieuses
j'ai vu des cas qu'était qui était
terrible donc je peux comprendre que les
gens ont besoin de sortir
que ce soit les étudiants qui souffre
énormément et on pourra jamais mettre un
degré sur la souffrance parce que ceux
qui se disent entre guillemets qui
pensent qu'il ya un ordre là haut qui
décide effectivement ce que le coc vide
et une partie de poker
mais je peux vous assurer que ce que
j'ai eu c'est tout sauf une grippe
voilà les gens souffrent encore et le
pire et pardonne moi de continuer
là-dessus at-il dit le pire c'est pas le
fait d'être en rien c'est la
convalescence posco vide quand ton corps
réagit très mal aux aux inflammations du
coc vide j'ai enchaîné les merdes j'ai
eu des douleurs je t'assure que je ne
souhaite pas mon pire ennemi
j'ai enchaîné une embolie pulmonaire ce
que j'ai enchaîné une
je me souviens plus du nom
voilà un épanchement pleural donc de
l'eau dans les poumons avec où j'ai un
traitement anticoagulant qui va qui va
traîner pendant de très longs mois et je
peux t'assurer que on souffre
terriblement n'arrive pas à tarif lui a
marché il faut cure après la marche et à
respirer
donc voilà donc il faut beaucoup d'amour
des gens autour de vous la famille c'est
important est de toute façon ceux qui
pensent que ce qu vide entre guillemets
est une plaisanterie le jour il le
frappe mais je leur souhaite pas de tout
coeur ils pourront comprendre mais je
dis aux témoignages ce soit à vous le
dire je repense à toutes les personnes
ici à ils ont dit oui au fossat va avoir
été fort et violent chez de vivre c'est
les vieux et ça c'est qu'il est moyen je
pense qu'on leur sortie rachat pu avoir
une personne qui dira ça sur ce plateau
ouais parce que vraiment vous nous dire
là je suis je pensais pas vraiment été
aussi en touche et maintenant c'est une
souffrance faut pas croire et j'en
souffre encore aujourd'hui parce qu'il
faut sauver folle à l'entraînement il
faut il faut prendre ton traitement sûr
que c'est pas je me souviens j'étais au
service des maladies infectieuses je
pouvais regarder la télé et j'avais
regardé l'émission il y avait un jeune
qui organisait des soirées un maillon de
300 personnes
tu sais les listes sont pleins il manque
de moyens je me disais si ces 300
personnes choper le coc vide et qu'ils
arrivaient en rien ouais qui est arrivé
d'abord en bas avant faut s'enregistrer
à bord et qui reste que dolly malaisie
battez-vous maintenant c'est une
catastrophe ce qui se passe là-bas et
est vraiment faut qu'il fasse attention
c'est des choses terribles qui se passer
de tout coeur faut qu'il fasse attention
tout simplement on pourra pas dire à
quelqu'un d'y croire ou ne pas croire
c'est comme un croyant
il croit en ce qu'il veut tu vois il va
pas le forcer à croire ce que tu crois
moi je parle de ce que j'ai vu ce que
j'ai subi et je le subis encore et je
vous remercie de m'avoir invité
ben écoute on était très vieux retour
[Applaudissements]